joining us at 11 o'clock i'm denise
feldas and i'm brian loftis changes
being discussed for downtown las vegas
after a few violent incidents right
along fremont street las vegas mayor
carolyn goodman working with police now
to consider a new curfew just for that
area madison kimbrough is live downtown
after hearing mixed reactions about that
proposal madison
it's 11 o'clock on a tuesday night and
as you can see the fremont street
experience is bustling with a lot of
traffic and people of all ages but a
possible curfew for those under 21 could
soon be enacted
it's not disneyland it's vegas they
shouldn't be out you know
it's an adult playground an increase in
violence along the fremont street
experience has city officials taking
action after several shootings including
a deadly attack two weeks ago mayor
carolyn goodman metro and our city
marshals committing to more law
enforcement in the area with a potential
curfew put in place for those under 21
years old tour is sharing whether they
agree with this potential curfew and if
the increase in crime deters them from
even wanting to be near the fremont
street experience it makes me a little
bit hesitant i mean 21 is a drinking age
so
what business does anybody under 21
have been out
late while the majority of people
understand the implications not everyone
feels like it will make the right impact
i don't think it is necessarily going to
solve any kind of problem i also don't
necessarily think it's anything
inherently bad i think i can see that
it's coming from a place of wanting to
keep young people safe just in line with
the drinking age of course i don't i
feel like there are probably better
steps one can take to fix the problem
though and it should be known that
there's already a curfew in place within
the experience for unaccompanied
children under the age of 18 as they
cannot be out without an adult from 9
p.m to 5 a.m friday and saturday and 10
p.m to 5 a.m sunday through thursday
this potential curfew for those under 21
was discussed in a meeting today with
mayor goodman and metro police but as of
now details on when this will be enacted
is unknown reporting live madison
kimbrough live local now